too many seats not enough butts
c is more efficient this way anyway
first reviewed back at e3 this year
idles montreal and square enix's
marvel's guardians of the galaxy is a
third-person action-adventure game that
is all about leaving out the adventures
of the wacky bunch of misfits
while trailers have revealed a little
bit more about the story and the
gameplay that is in store
geek culture had the pleasure of a
hands-on preview and here are some of
our thoughts
without a shadow of a doubt the team is
in the spotlight here the lights of
groot star-lord drax gamora and rocket
will be the stars of the show when it
comes to marvel's guardians of the
galaxy
with the team still in its early days it
is clear that not everyone is on the
same page
player interactions and dialogue choices
will impact not just your relationships
with the rest of the guardians but also
affect some parts of the game as well
allowing players to get to know the
guardians all over again is a great way
for idols montreal to differentiate
their game from the movie counterparts
the team has also made use of the milano
the home base of the guardians to add
more to their environmental storytelling
curious players will be able to find
items that relate to the different
characters and reflect their
personalities in ways that you never
thought possible as the game progresses
the team has promised that there will be
more for players to find and more
interactions to have as you get to know
the guardians better
going back to the fact that actions have
consequences we also came to a point in
the demo where we found an abandoned
nova call helmet with voices ringing
from the other side we had the decision
to make whether to respond or to keep
silent
depending on the choices that you made
as the leader of the guardians things
might pan out differently than other
playthroughs
for instance if you are kept quiet the
nova corps will not be alert to your
presence and you can get the drop on
them
conversely if you are spoke into the
helmet the whole station will be alerted
to your whereabouts and start attacking
immediately
this brings us to combat where a team of
5 going up against overwhelming numbers
is bound to be a chaotic affair
however this is where the game kind of
falters a little bit
players will be controlling star lord
while the rest of the guardians go about
their business
as peter quill you'll be able to fire
off your normal shots as well as
elemental shots if enemies get too close
for comfort you can bash them away with
a melee attack here and there and of
course you can depend on the various
abilities that star lord has in order to
beat the odds
this applies to the rest of the
guardians as well with a press of the
left bumper bringing up a menu of
abilities that you can activate at any
time
it is by combining all the right
abilities at the right time for the
right foes then you would have a better
chance of succeeding
with the overwhelming numbers at times
as well as different enemy types that
bring different abilities to the table
things can get hectic fast and you might
not always have the best view of the
battlefield
this might just be the case for the demo
itself but if the rest of the combat in
marvel's guardians of the galaxy is as
chaotic as this then players will
probably need more time to get up to
speed
there are also the systems that are in
play during combat that can add to the
experience
the idea of momentum is to see how
players are engaged in the combat and
whether they are doing the right things
by chaining attacks together and pulling
off the right moves you're building up a
momentum meter that can allow for more
contact specific actions and combos that
can do more damage to the enemies this
will also result in team moves where the
whole guardians of the galaxy come
together to pull off a damaging attack
on any particular enemy
the better you do the better your
ranking at the end of the encounter and
that can result in bonus xp as well
which will go a long way in unlocking
new abilities for your guardians
there is also a separate huddle mechanic
where peter quill brings in the rest of
the guardians together for a pep talk as
ridiculous as it sounds it is definitely
in line with the style of the game as
well as the characters involved
judging from keywords that float up
behind the guardians as well as their
general mood players will need to choose
the right pep talk to give in order to
unleash bonuses for your characters
do it correctly and the whole team gets
a boost to your combat abilities as well
as their cooldowns if not only star lord
gets the bonus
comes to the audio and visuals presented
in marvel's guardians of the galaxy it
is clear that idols montreal has put
plenty of work into it to get in things
right
despite the preview missing some of the
more fancy bells and whistles things are
really looking great character models
look very detailed animations are smooth
and while they may not look the same as
their movie counterparts these
particular guardians are lucas
themselves as well
music is definitely a big part of
marvel's guardians of the galaxy
with idles montreal depending on both
licensed music as well as their own
creations to power the game
the fact that the team has created their
own album starring the fictional band
star lord which pitocio got his name
from it's a testament to the commitment
to getting things right
the music sets the mood perfectly
whether it be a combat a scenario or
just exploring around the different
environments in the game and we look
forward to getting our heads bopping to
the bank soundtrack in the future
at the end of the day marvel's guardians
of the galaxy was always going to have a
hill to climb comparisons to the movies
will be made
while the gameplay and the team dynamics
will come into the spotlight judging
from the time that we have spent with
the game itself
the guardians of the galaxy are on the
right path
however the action sequences could do
with a little bit more tweaking to let
it shine
either way everyone will have the chance
to become a hero when marvel's guardians
of the galaxy launches this coming 26
october
and for all the latest news updates on
movies tv shows games toys and tech you
are already in the right place
[Music]
you